yeah those b-52 strikes john wanted them
badly of course priority was going a lot
of other areas
uh one thing that i do point out in the
book peter kama before he became the the
brigade
advisor
was working with the uh commander of of
all forces in vietnam uh
the deputy commander at the time general
wayan so he had a connection to the top
levels of of the
command in vietnam and was able to
leverage that uh on
a couple of occasions to get some p-52
strikes diverted
but yeah john wanted those b-52s badly
and and he got that that first one uh
that night just after midnight
what's the closest you ever were when
one of those arc light strikes oh it was
a good ways away
uh it sounds like they were just
insane yeah before that john thinks that
he was the first one and i i've not been
able to confirm but john thinks he was
the first one to work b-52 strikes in
that close of proximity to friendly
forces
before that they were always tried to
keep him 500 meters away
he brought that down to 300 meters i
think in one case i don't remember was
this one or the next one but they said
hey you got to be at least 500 meters
away and john said yeah we are close but
no knowing he wasn't nearly that far
away
yeah it just turns i think you said
three
football fields
in length just total destruction just
destroys everything in that area it is a
normal arc light would be three b-52s
flying in in formation and and letting
all their bombs go that's quite quite a
massive
path of destruction